a Barbie has been every girl's favorite
toy for decades and while we love that
we have the chance to have a lot of
different dolls the towel also made some
mistakes along the way
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know which Barbie turned out to
be really dangerous for children if you
love Barbies as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a thumbs up today we are showing
you the 10 most inappropriate Barbie
dolls that actually exist the Oreo
Barbie it all started with a partnership
with Oreo cookies but it turned out to
be incredibly wrong we all love cookies
and all the different ways to eat it so
we wonder how something bad can happen
with them but matau just didn't think
that Oreo was also an offensive slang
against people of color it is used to
talk about a black person who is
regarded as having adopted the attitude
the values and the behaviors associated
with white society often at the expense
of their own heritage and you should
never take that as a compliment so an
Oreo can be an incredibly good or
incredibly bad thing and by making the
Barbie black they made people think that
this girl was portrayed as too white
just like the cookie she was black on
the outside and white on the inside
Oreo and Mattel never intended to share
this message but it still happened and
it turned out to be pretty offensive to
some people we have no problem with a
partnership with another brand of
cookies but just ask more people about
it when you come up with an idea
the totally tattoo Barbie a couple of
years ago having a tattoo made you feel
special but nowadays you probably feel
more special if there is no ink on your
skin because everyone is now turned into
a work of art and Barbie is not an
exception with the tokidoki Barbie kids
had the opportunity to add tattoos to
their favorites all the totally stylin
tattoos Barbie included over 40 easy no
mess tattoos at tattoo Stamper and
additional fashions the game was not
only about putting temporary tattoos on
Barbie skin they had the chance to put
it on their skin too it was not the
first time that we saw kids playing with
temporary tattoos but this time parents
thought that Mattel took it way too far
they said that it might encourage kids
to get tattoos even though they are way
too young for this many parents thought
it wasn't that bad and how they saw what
many call a [ __ ] stamp with the name of
their
Boyfriend on the back of their kids doll
while this one last tattoo is not really
kid-friendly
we don't see any problem with temporary
tattoos of things like a heart or star
stop the prejudice and let kids know
that grown-ups with tattoos can be good
role models too but while they don't
really know what they want Tiberi
tattoos can't be harmful at all the teen
talk Barbie when we were kids Barbie
used to be our best friend we could tell
her anything we wanted and unlike our
mom she wasn't going to answer with
anything weird but some girls ended up
feeling lonely when their Barbie didn't
answer this was when Mattel came up with
the team talk Barbie so our favorite
doll could speak to us and as soon as
kids started playing with it parents
wish that she never got the chance to
talk that's because Barbie could only
say things like will we ever have enough
clothes or I love shopping there is
nothing wrong with a girl who loves
fashion but when this is the only thing
she can say we think that it doesn't
make her the best role model for little
girls and the American Association of
University Women became really offended
when Barbie said math class is tough as
if doing something other than being
pretty was too complicated for her The
Simpsons even criticized it in Lisa vs.
Malibu Stacy when her doll said things
like thinking too much gives you
wrinkles we think that children should
just use their imagination and think
that barbie could say greater things
than that if she could speak what about
a Barbie who wants to start her own
business or a doll who doesn't care
about boys like Ken and just wants to
spend time with her friends
now that's something we would want to
hear the Barbie video girl now that's a
Barbie who has ambition this time the
doll wanted to become a filmmaker and
let kids film themselves the Barbie was
a real working video camera that gave
kids a chance to create movies from
Barbie's point of view with a full-color
LCD screen more than 25 minutes of
recording time and real-time playback it
was a chance for kids to be the heroes
of their own stories unfortunately video
girl was not the best name for Barbie
that's because a video girl is actually
a beautiful woman in a bikini who dances
around in the background of rap videos
this is not a bad thing but this is not
the only thing girls should aspire to be
why can't they talk about Barbie being a
filmmaker and said or just a normal
actress that would be a better ambition
for young girls who want to work in the
movie industry but the biggest problem
was that people thought that giving a
camera to a kid could turn into
something really inappropriate people
with bad intentions could take advantage
of kids to get the video that they want
and sell it on a website for adults this
is why we don't suggest giving a camera
to your kid until they are teenagers or
at least really make sure that
everything is okay when they are using
one the Barbie happy family one of the
greatest things that a woman can aspire
to be is a mother and Mattel wanted to
teach children about family life this is
why many kids were interested in the
Barbie happy family also called pregnant
midge she was one of Barbie's best
friends and she literally had a baby
inside her yes she didn't only have a
bulging belly
you could also clearly see a small
classic baby in her abdomen this is also
what made her a little bit creepy and we
wouldn't be surprised if it gave kids
nightmares with so many details on how a
baby grows inside a woman's body kids
started asking too many questions and
their parents weren't ready yet to talk
about the birds and the bees but the
main reason why pregnant midge was
controversial is that she didn't have a
wedding ring many people thought that
she looked way too young to have a kid
and it encouraged teen pregnancy while
some teenagers can become really good
mothers most girls are not ready yet and
Barbie shouldn't make them think that
it's normal to have a kid at that age
moreover she didn't come with a husband
which made people think that she just
spent the night with him before he left
her anyway that wasn't a happy story
parents wish their kids could find a
better way to start a family the Barbie
in a wheelchair we love diversity and
this is why we're really happy to see a
Barbie in a wheelchair little girls need
to have good role models like this to
believe that they can be beautiful too
this time Barbie had another friend
called Becky who was in a wheelchair and
she didn't let anyone stop her from
doing what she wants as she was also the
school photographer it all started with
the simple share a smile Becky and the
young doll even later got the chance to
participate in the Paralympics in her
wheelchair
Becky quickly became a great inspiration
for young girls she learned that there
was nothing wrong with being in a
wheelchair this is why you're probably
wondering what the problem is the Barbie
in a wheelchair looks like a perfect
idea but there was actually one little
thing that people complained about a
high school student named Kirstie
Johnson found out that
chair wouldn't fit into the elevator at
Barbie's Dreamhouse and it didn't make
sense for her that the only girl who
really needs to use the elevator can't
fit in it
Mattel later fix this problem so we hope
that Becky will have the chance to shine
once again this one was actually a good
role model and she simply leaves a
little more space to show it the Mexican
Barbie here is another example of
diversity Mattel gave us the chance to
travel all around the world to discover
new cultures on the website you could
read hola
welcome to Mexico the Barbie was
inspired by traditional mariachis and
marimbas to be ready for an atheistic
she wore a bright pink ruffled dress
with colorful lace and ribbon accents
the doll even included a passport
country stickers a Chihuahua friends and
a brush people from all around the world
said that the doll looks beautiful and
the world collection was a great idea
however those who really knew about the
Mexican culture said that Mattel really
got it wrong some of them said if the
doll is part of the world collection and
it's representing the Mexican culture
and the Chihuahua should not be with the
doll the Chihuahua has never been a
symbol or a mascot to represent Mexico
and she was not the only controversial
doll many people criticize the
simplistic portrayals of different
heritage and complained that the images
looked very dated as if they had been
created for a different time Mattel
replied that they did their best to
represent the Mexican culture by
consulting the Mexican Embassy but it
looks like it wasn't enough we think
that a more recent portrayal of the
dolls would have been more appropriate
the slumber party barbie this doll was
sold a long time ago in 1965 so we
understand why Mattel was still making
little mistakes at that time but we
don't understand why no one in the 60s
spoke out to say that this doll was just
a terrible role model for young girls
Barbie was going to his sleepover and
there was nothing wrong with that until
we found out what the girls were doing
there the slumber party Barbie came with
a pink scale and was permanently set at
110 pounds we know that Barbie is
probably really tall but let's say she
is 5 9 she would already be 35 pounds
underweight if she weighed 110 pounds
actually she wouldn't even be able to
stand up if she was so thin because her
proportions are too unrealized
and that's not the most terrible thing
she also came with the book how to lose
weight as if she wasn't skinny enough
and you know what was the books only
advice don't eat Mattel dropped the
scale the last year but the Barbie was
still sold with the diet book for a
couple of years we can't believe that
they got away with a toy that promotes
anorexia we were going to forgive them
for Barbies unrealistic proportions but
now we think that they have taken things
way too far the growing up skipper
Barbie growing up is just a part of our
lives and young girls will one day have
to find out about it they will not only
become taller but they will also have
more curves including breasts and this
is exactly what Mattel wanted to teach
them with growing up skipper in 1975
skipper used to be a young girl just
like the kids playing with her but
Mattel later came up with a new doll
that could grow up if her arms were
rotated she would become half an inch
taller and small breasts would appear
under her torso on the box you could
even read the dog grows from cute little
girl to a tall and curvy teenager with a
set of pretty clothes for each time of
her life a couple of years later skipper
was finally a real grown-up with a super
teen skipper her new body mold included
small permanent breasts and she also had
a slightly different new face to make
her look older it was not totally a bad
idea
after all it is normal for our bodies to
change and kids probably already notice
that their big sister didn't look the
same but we think that many parents
weren't ready to talk about puberty with
their little girls or actually we think
that pregnant midge and growing up
skipper would be a great way to teach
kids about the birds and the bees the
pooper-scooper barbie just when we
thought that barbie couldn't be more
inappropriate the pooper-scooper barbie
was actually a risk for children's lives
this time barbie was a professional dog
walker which is a really nice job for a
young woman who loves animals
it came with a really cute dog that was
maybe a little bit too realistic and
it's not only because it was soft and
fuzzy and then its mouth ears head and
tell really moved it's because the dog
could eat his food and later poop it out
then barbie could pick up the poop with
her magnetic pooper scooper even though
it's really weird and a little
disgusting we think there is nothing
wrong with teaching kids that they
should clean up after their dog after an
- so what was wrong with this dog kids
started swallowing the little parts of
the toy it's not really surprising and
we shouldn't let kids that are too young
play with this but the problem was that
with the magnets it became much more
dangerous than any other toy they had to
go to the hospital because it could be
life-threatening this is why Barbie
forever and Tana the dog were recalled
but don't worry if they were quickly
replaced by Barbie and her walk and
potty pop with no magnets which doll do
you think was the most inappropriate
don't be shy in the comment section down
below we'd love to hear what you think
and that's it for 10 most inappropriate
Barbie dolls that actually exists for
more stories like this make sure you
watch xx toys no kid would want to
receive for Christmas thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]